Hi, I'm Jessica Alba.
I'm Christopher Gavigan.
I'm Brian Lee.
And I'm Sean Kane.
Together, we are the founders of The Honest Company.
And we believe that the simplest of actions can have a big impact.
So please join us in our "I Will If You Will" challenge for Earth Hour 2013.
So here it is: If 10,000 of you pledge to use nontoxic products in your home,...
...we will let our kids dress all Honest employees for the day.
And you know how creative kids can get with dress-up.
And as parents, we believe that we have the responsibility to safeguard our children's future...
...by creating the safest and most sustainable environment for them.
You could learn more about our story and join the conversation by visiting Honest.com.
And don't forget to turn off your lights for Earth Hour...
...on Saturday, March 23rd, 2013 at 8:30 PM.
Together, we can make it better.